[Music]
Gwen Stefani gets candid about
collaborating with her boyfriend Blake
Shelton et's Katy Kraus caught up with
the pop superstar at kiss FM's Wango
Tango on Saturday duet - it's been stuck
in my head
why don't you do it
the to voice coaches are taking their
romantic duo to the 2016 Billboard Music
Awards stage on May 22nd but Stefani
admits the duo isn't quite ready are you
and Blake rehearsing right now for next
Sunday's performance and what's that
like or not we probably should
it was amazing doing that song live it's
incredible - do you know any time I've
ever collaborated with anyone it's
always my favorite but to do something
with him because he's so talented and he
becomes like such a different world and
to make music together it was it was
just so shocking
it's just so fun to have new music
especially when I have not written a
good song that I love and I'll such a
long time and this record happened so
fast and it was such a shock that I
could get into that place the reception
I mean you must be over the moon with
how many lives you're touching like I
prayed for that like I promise you like
I just so badly wanted to make something
good out of something bad like I had to
I knew that that was my duty here I'm
saying like everybody has a cross to
bear I was like I was like okay I got to
do this I got to make this happen
[Music]